it's a busy news day in hong kong
is out covering the hot stories
meteors in hong kong are busy following
president xi jinping who has come to
hong kong and
democrats are preparing for the rally
and some kind of
demonstration
such events may be common in many
countries but in hong kong they're
highly
sensitive media coverage of them will be
under close scrutiny
many journalists here in hong kong say
they're less and less free to report
especially when it comes to issues like
the influence of the beijing government
or the calls for free elections here in
hong kong or even for hong kong's
independence
la minpong has been a reporter in hong
kong for more than 10 years
today he works for radio free asia a u.s
public media outlet
previously he had a job at a big
commercial tv channel in hong kong
until he says his editors watered down a
report on police violence against a
protester during the pro-democracy
umbrella movement in 2014.
he and some of his co-workers filed a
complaint that's when the trouble began
for those reporters
who have signed
that petition including me
we feel that the company is trying to
force you out of the company after the
incident
they will just maybe put you into some
kind of
meaningless
or
not significant assignments
and make you feel frustrated and then
send a clear message to you that
you have no future in this company just
so you better leave
it's difficult to exactly pinpoint
beijing's influence on the hong kong
media
it's not censorship in the classic sense
many journalists here say the methods
are more subtle
i mean ching chung a veteran hong kong
journalist
he spent three years in a chinese prison
for espionage a fabricated allegation he
says
chiang chang believes he was locked up
because he wrote a critical article
about china's handling of a border
dispute with russia
he says beijing is trying to pressure
critical journalists in hong kong
we have beijing's a
watchdog organization here the central
liaison office
the central liaison office will try to
have
regular
informal
dinner or lunch gatherings with the top
management of the
media outlets in hong kong
advising them what to report and what
not to report and people will then begin
to second guess
and
once you second guess you try to be
always on the safe side
and that means that
you voluntarily exercise some sort of
self-censorship
but the pressure does not only come from
the authorities
in recent years several of hong kong's
media outlets have been bought by
businessmen with close ties to china's
ruling communist party the most
prominent example is probably this one
the south china morning post it's the
most prestigious english language daily
in hong kong and it's been around for
over 100 years
last year it was bought by alibaba
china's equivalent to amazon and alibaba
is led by jack ma china's richest man
at the hong kong journalists association
they're afraid that the south china
morning post will be forced to give up
the critical reporting it was once known
for
jeff mars
people have already made it quite clear
that they they don't they want the scmp
to become a kind of a voice of china a
window of china to tell the chinese
story
from
i guess from a mainland perspective in
order to kind of balance
what they see as a buyer's
coverage
in western media on
china and on hong kong
for hong kong's journalists beijing's
rising influence means critical
reporting is more and more becoming a
phenomenon of the
thank
past